ansley's with us in
uh athens georgia hi ansley how are you
hey dave hey anthony thank y'all for
taking my call
sure what's up well i just actually
finished reading
total money makeover about an hour ago
and throughout the book
uh one thing that kept speaking to me
was
that we paid are we financed i'm sorry
more car than we should have um so i
have a 20 20 suburban that we got back
in april
and we owe 64 000 on it so
throughout the book that was one thing
that just kept popping and i said we got
to get rid of this car so this past
weekend we went to
a couple different dealerships one said
i don't
want your car and the other one wanted
me to take a ten thousand dollar loss
in order for them to take my to my car
so
i i i'm at a loss as to what to do
in order to take this big chunk out of
our debt what do you owe on it
uh 64 000 currently okay and what's the
mar what's the market value if you
looked it up on kbb
um they told me about 56 with
with it being an excellent condition
since we've only had it for a few months
is that trade-in or is that private sale
yeah that's just
trading yeah that means they're going to
make the money on it right
okay number if you sell this car to an
individual you can probably get out of
it
yeah okay but it's not gonna but but
that's a
hard that's an expensive car to sell to
an individual
very difficult car to sell sixty four
thousand dollar car loan yeah we have
four kids
we need we needed some big cameras i
know
i know we should have read total money
makeover a few months ago but i just
discovered it and and now we're here and
you know we can't what is your household
income
uh we bring home about 9 500 a month
yeah you need to sell it yeah you don't
have to panic
and you don't have to give it away but
you do need to sell it right
all right it was an unreasonable
purchase in your situation
and uh that's being kind it is
i i get that and so um
but i i mean it may take you a while
you're either going to take a
10 000 loss by selling it to a dealer at
wholesale or you're going to take a
while to sell it
and you know get the use of it during
that time and
how much other debt have you guys got
not counting your home
um total it's 164.
what's the other 100 um we owe
3200 or 32 000 on my husband's truck
we have uh just over 55 000 in student
loans
um and then a few
small credit cards so almost a hundred
thousand dollars in car payments
yes wow here's oh more on your cars than
you make
yeah oh my god that's rough but here's
here's the thing
actually i'm ainsley you just joined the
family so welcome to the family
thank you i'm just crying with you yeah
we both are i know here's what i would
do if i was in your situation
i will put that card and what i would
try and do because
every time you drive that car the value
is going to go down if you are going to
sell that
car which we are suggesting that you do
i would try and figure out how you all
can keep the miles low on that
and then i would say you know what
husband we need to take a 5 000
minimum loss we may have to take the 10
000. and give yourself a time
frame so if the car is not sold by this
date
yeah you're just going to take the loss
one month yeah
give it a month put up for sale see if
you can move it for a month after that
you need to take the loss you you've got
such a big mess you've got to move on
this
um what's his truck worth um
i think they said 30. about what he owes
on it
yeah i'd put it up for sale too yeah
okay yeah you guys have a car mess you
need to buy two five thousand dollar
cars and get back to reality
okay and all right
and they make make five thousand dollar
cars it'll carry four kids it's just a
big van okay
just get you a big old cheap fan and um
buckle them in and go i yeah
yeah you're gonna you're gonna feel like
you've lost 300 pounds
i mean you're just you're being their
car payments are two thousand dollars a
month
it really is not dave you know the
average you know the listeners out there
saying dave
just told them to sell both their cars
and go get five thousand dollar cars
yeah so what's wrong with that nothing
at all good
but i wouldn't ask you this because i
know people are thinking well dave
at what point can i get a nice car when
you can pay cash and win the total of
your vehicles equals less than half your
annual income
they have one car yeah that both of
their cars are
almo one's over half their annual income
one's almost half their annual income
right
and so you know his truck is out of line
yeah
you know if you're gonna have two cars
and you make 90 two cars equaling 45
that's a couple of 20 000 cars
that you pay cash for neither one of
these cars
are that yeah and if he's going to drive
a 30 000 truck that means she's going to
be driving
a 5 000 car yeah the rest of her life
right you know until they get their
income up because you don't need to
spend more than half your annual income
on things with motors and wheels
because they all go down in value you're
not
going to become wealthy doing that and
i'm not preaching at her i'm just saying
in general i'll answer your question
yeah
because she's she's had the discovery
but now it's gonna now comes the pain
yeah and because it's a dramatic shift
from a 64 000 2020 suburban
i know to a hooptie yeah i felt everyone
listening right now oh my gosh
well but you know what you should be oh
my gosh the other way yeah
how scared i am for her absolutely and
her family i don't know how in the crud
they qualified for the loan
yeah i mean what was the car dealer
smoking i don't know
i don't know either 64 000 at this
interest rate right now that's easy
a twelve hundred thirteen hundred dollar
car no payment oh it's more than